speaking of sucking on tits and estrogen
do you want to work what a [ __ ] wow
shake these titties
[Music]
um alyssa milano who's the boss is
coming back
everybody's doing reboots of old shows
and the truth of the situation is
bubba's they don't
work but alyssa milanos are working girl
because alyssa milano who's
apparently the chairperson of the dnc i
don't know how that happened
she became everyone's political guru uh
you know with her previous experience of
being a child
actress on who's the boss with tony
danza well guess what
who's the boss is back here's to another
show that
nobody asked for to come back i mean
what the [ __ ] is alyssa milano going to
do in the show she's a grown woman now
because she's she going to be antifa
yeah she's just going to talk about
um you know some policies on the show
and she's going to
talk about how joe rogan's podcast is
three times as big as hers
did you see that tweet when she said oh
my god joe rogan's
uh yeah she said we live in a world
where joe rogan's podcast is three times
as big as mine
and it was funny because everyone
trolled her and said bash
it's much bigger than three times it was
so funny everyone was like three times
it's yeah
it's a lot i don't even know alyssa
milano has a podcast v do you listen to
alyssa milano's podcast
no i don't did you find a parking spot
yet
she did listen to carly and emma and
everyone's really upset that they broke
up
yeah well what can you do i mean we'd
like let's get them on the show let's
get carly and emma on the show
that'd be great well i'd love to get
them both in the show at the same time
so she said we live in a world where joe
rogan's pocket says triple the listeners
is mine
dear god dear god and what did she say a
football team
has to [ __ ] yeah yeah who knows a
major sports team because their name is
so horribly offensive
yeah shut up yeah whenever i see her
tweet i just hear ya
i know it's just one of those does she
have kids i wonder if she has kids
i don't know does she know do we know
most most
most of the women like they just don't
because i just think when you become a
mom you just like
you want to make changes but you're just
[ __ ] exhausted oh she has three kids
okay
i'll tell you what though when i was a
kid watching the show i'm saying this
from the perspective of being a kid at
the time she was the number one piece in
the country
oh no she's a great actress who's the
boss in her mood they're great i mean
it's a great
show very talented but yeah twitter is
just like it's you know
people are mentally insane on twitter
yeah well i mean i i disagree on the
talent i mean you know i mean anyone
could have [ __ ] played tony danza's
boss
i mean i think they hired a bad actress
on purpose
because they wanted it to match tony
danza yeah tony [ __ ] dance
because tony danza was at the was that
the feast was that the san gennaro's
feast
serving [ __ ] rice balls that's a true
story
tony danza is the original squeak
i mean is there a crazier [ __ ] sweep
to tony danza
because he's a failed boxer he's a
squeak and
he somehow became an actor i mean the
kids want
the kid has sticks though he's got a
couple sticks from who's the boss no
oh no i think he's got i think tony
danza might have real [ __ ] money hold
on let me i think tony danza might have
like
real money let's look it up because i
swear to you not he was working a
stand at the san ginero feast selling
rice balls now that could just be
because italians can't stay away from
[ __ ] street fares
not a kid's worth 40 mil so i mean the
kid's got
sticks he's got sticks but that just
lets you know a little bit about
how much of a real italian he was i
swear to god if you go to the san
general feast he's oh he's there every
year i think he's got like a stand
and i had his chicken palm sandwich and
i just got to be honest it was not that
good i'm sorry tony
ray review us subscribe uh turn on your
notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild
huh